once upon a time a few months back we
all gave our pics for an underrated
superhero movie today we're flipping at
around so welcome to council of geeks my
name is Nathaniel Wayne and I am joined
tonight by for God's sake I am joined by
these two Schmucks by Paul scavino and
Ryan Daly and we have all got a pic for
what we consider to be an overrated
superhero film Paul why don't you why
don't you kick us off this time my pick
for the most overrated Marvel film it
was a Marvel just a severe superheroes
we're opening up changing it no all
right I'm over my pick for most
overrated superhero film is age of
Ultron ah now this let me be very clear
I enjoyed this movie I suppose this work
I'll just interject there there is a
difference between saying something is
overrated
and saying something is bad right
there's really a one only one other film
you can compare this movie to right
which is the original Avengers film is
it unfair perhaps on the Avengers film
did something that no other film in
history had done and delivered on it
brilliantly I thought so why didn't
think this one worked was that I felt it
was bloated in terms of the characters I
thought that was one of the issues that
the original Avengers film had but
somehow through the brilliance of Joss
Whedon he was actually able to balance
all this out into this one whose movie
is this I understand it's an ensemble
film right but at the center of this
film right is Tony Stark in this movie I
feel like should probably be a
discussion about reaching too far which
is where Ultron comes from it's through
Tony's arrogance that he makes this
decision he builds Ultron and he doesn't
listen to the very good advice that he
was given not to do this right and that
by the end of the film he is face to
face with this thing that he has created
and needs to destroy it and hopefully
has learned a lesson I would argue that
we don't get that
is the answer to defeating Ultron at the
end of this film is Tony brings out the
other self you know thinking Android
with the Infinity stone right and that's
what ends up saving the day I also think
the vision was wildly underused and a
huge disappointment but so if this is
Tony's story I don't get what the lesson
is for him or how he is a better person
for having gone through these trials and
what he's learned from it so that's my
sort of big issue with this I wanted it
to be more personal I wanted all Tron's
his hatred of Tony to be more pointedly
attacked at him I think there were too
many characters I introduced into this
film I don't think they had enough time
to deal with any of these sort of real
character arcs I thought they dropped
the ball with Tony
I think Black Widow remains a character
that has been basically given nothing to
do the farm with Hawkeye I thought the
movies pacing completely fell apart all
right so let me long-run let me ask you
a question guess who d whose story was
the first Avengers if age of Ultron is
Tony's story it does it then yes those
problems you mentioned are legitimate
but I think you're viewing it through a
lens that it's not intended to be viewed
through and so that's why I'm asking ya
whose store was the first Avengers so I
would say I just needed a second to
think about the first film I would say
that by and large the first film was
really Thor story he doesn't even show
up for 40 minutes yeah I guess yeah I
think Tony emerges from the first one
the most changed and the most sort of
myth it seems like Tony is the one who
has the catharsis well unless yeah at
the end of it even though it really
feels like all ready the first half of
it feels like Nick Fury's movie had
shields mm-hmm
the beginning of age of Ultron feels
very much like Tony is driving this and
then at that moment where he is
confronted with I've made this horrible
mistake
we don't see him atoning for it in any
way that seems like this is
consequences following actions it's kind
of a weird thing and I feel like at that
point the story is taken away from him
and given to both Captain America and
the vision I agree with a lot of what
you're saying I also hate you for for
bringing these things if you watched our
other podcasts previously on console
geeks um the the reason I am so excited
for civil war right is that that this
movie is going to be about Tony and
Steve's relationship right and his in
Steve's relationship with Bucky right
and what they are doing the things that
they believe in and the stuff they stand
for it's can be putting this kind of
crucible right and we're gonna see these
really important character pieces coming
out of this would argue that we don't
see a whole lot of that in Ultron I
almost feel like you could have replaced
a lot of the heroes with other ones and
it wouldn't it mattered age of Ultron is
a slightly odd movie for me because if I
look at any individual part of it almost
every part of it I like or love and in
some cases more so than the first movie
but something about the way it is
assembled and put together does not work
as well which I think speaks to your
issue of well this feels like Tony's
story because that first Avengers movie
I don't think you can definitively say
it's any one character story but the
what the first movie did was it was
assembled in such a way that the focus
could shift and flow from Nick Fury -
Tony - cap to Thor and you it just felt
like a natural progression
something about the way Ultron was put
together left you with an impression
well this feels like Tony sorry and then
would have moved away from that you
didn't go with it the way that you went
with it the first time the first
Avengers was just a great story like
built structurally it's perfect and it
did have that emotional wow factor that
going into that history Avengers age of
Ultron didn't have those things the
story the structure was not out there it
felt like something that was all over
the place and maybe needed an extra 45
minutes to
sense of all these different things or
else cut a whole lot of them and make it
a leaner movie but also as I fan gave me
that those things that I did want and I
did want all Tron I didn't want the
twins I didn't want vision and I didn't
want to see Captain America actually
become the leader of The Avengers the
first Avengers is a much better movie
but the second Avengers gave me more of
those things that I liked as a fan
that's adds age of Ultron um Ryan what
have you got
Days of Future past x-men Days of Future
past for me was a big disappointment
some of my problems with x-men Days of
Future past are admittedly preconceived
notions and expectations but one of
those things like when they went to
comic-con and they brought up 16 actors
on the stage I was like I'm gonna see a
giant team of like 16 x-men character
who's gonna be great and I always want
to see this guy and then I watch
something's like well they died she died
again they've not characters they're
power sets they're just used and all it
was was the same people again
I like Xavier I like magneto I like
Wolverine I like mystique but I've been
with them for seven movies now x-men has
a hundred different characters you can
choose from but that's not an objective
that's not a problem with the movie
itself that was a problem with me and
what I want my problem with the movie
itself is that okay yes it chose to
focus on Xavier magneto mystique and
Wolverine and I thought it ruined Xavier
magneto and mystique none of the things
they did made sense or were good
starting with Xavier okay we end the
last movie with him paralyzed now he can
walk but the side effect of him being
wah or him learning to walk is he can't
use his powers and he's grown a beard
and looks like a dirty hippie
and he acts like a heroin junkie well
that logic doesn't even track why is
okay so he's he's gonna grow into them
be the man who run right Xavier yeah he
already was so why are you backsliding
the character to bring him back to the
hero that we needed them to be so okay
then you've got magneto that's like so
we convinced magneto that he needs to
work for the greater good to stop this
Sentinel program by stopping this
assassination and he saves mystique free
he stops her from doing that mistake
so that he can make the same mistake
knowing what these consequences are okay
he's going to do that because he's a bad
guy
and it didn't feel like a natural logic
of what the character is facing in the
scenes it was the same thing that
happened at the end of the previous film
on the beach yeah he turns bad because
he's bad the thing that everybody loves
the the scene with Quicksilver sure and
I've had this conversation with people
between the Quicksilver of x-men Days of
Future past and the Quicksilver of age
of Ultron give me the one from age of
Ultron why he was there was nowhere near
as good well yeah the scene the age of
Days of Future past was an amazing scene
that was a beautiful scene right that's
all it was he wasn't a character I
didn't like that movie and a lot of
people it was among their best movie
best comic book group action movies of
the year I was like why it didn't give
you it didn't give me all the characters
that I want to see and the ones that it
did focus on I didn't think made sense
I've already played this movie before
well I was you're on my side yeah it's
gotta fall to me Joe say defend this
film could Paul's in your corner yep so
okay I'm not gonna address so many
characters who are only processing
because you yourself a minute that part
of the issue there was your expectation
I really liked that they brought Charles
down a few pegs and here's why because
if they didn't that means that he has
been an Angelica Aragon of virtue and
has never ever changed or grown or had
an arc or had to build up from anything
he's just always known what's best he's
always done what's best he's just always
been that good bull I I I like that they
brought him down in that they gave him
something to recover from and there was
also a big logistical thing they had to
have a reason that his power didn't work
otherwise the movie is 20 minutes long
in regards to Magneto
I think his actions made perfect sense
because it's all rooted in arrogance
because he is arrogant enough to be told
these are the consequences of what's
going on you have to help us change that
and he's arrogant enough to go okay it
went wrong because you people did I can
do it and make it
work see you sold it to me better just
now than the movie sold
I also absolutely loved the way it ended
I loved the concluding note on it it
just felt like a wonderful closure to
the old version of x-men thinking about
Xavier and and needing him to fall a
little bit I have no problem with him in
suffering and having setbacks because
you do want to see a little bit of
change in the character I think they
went a little bit overboard looking at
the source material
Xavier wasn't the focus he wasn't he was
always the support he was the mentor but
it was never his story and that's the
thing that the movies have chosen to do
and I think I went on about 20 minutes
about why I hated the ending so okay so
my pick for an overrated comic-book
movie is Captain America the First
Avenger which unless something has
changed I believe it's still Paul's
favorite comic book movie of all them is
it still not number one spot yeah okay
I'm not doing this to troll you this is
not payback for Moonraker it's just a
happy coincidence I see it show up on so
many people's lists not just you so many
people put put it in this high ranking
yo that was so great and I look at that
and go why because here's the thing that
movie so far as I'm concerned had one
job to do and that was to sell me on
Steve Rogers and Captain America as a
character and on that one job it's it
absolutely succeeds I came away
immediately going I want to see more of
that character I also came away going I
don't ever need to see that movie again
all the other elements going on around
him are middling to passable it let's
start with some of the supporting cast
Tommy Lee Jones was a great get and a
terrific presence and he was asleep in
this movie Dominic Cooper as Howard
Stark is a caricature of a character
Haley Atwell as Peggy Carter within the
confines of this movie is stereotypical
woman strong woman ahead of her time and
that's about it
there is stuff done with her later on
that does the character much better
Bucky is fine he feels the best friend
role I feel like the connection between
him and Steve was done
much better in Winter Soldier flashbacks
the the Howling Commandos the only one I
remember at all is dumped Dum Dugan I
think that's only because of the name
and the mustache my big problem with
this movie the villains and people have
been clamoring for the Red Skull to come
back and I can't figure out why but I'll
get back to him I decided because I want
to start with hydra hydra to me in this
movie feels like Cobra from GI Joe the
cartoon version it never at any point
this movie feels like they have the
upper hand or that they're winning or
that they're even that big a threat
we're told at various points are there
everything that we see visually is
always them being bitten back there's a
montage that is nothing but then being
beaten back and as far as the Red Skull
is concerned he looks phenomenal
and it's a bland generic mad scientist
mustache twirling performance there's
absolutely nothing exceptional about it
it's fine yeah that's definitely from
the guy who directed Jurassic Park 3
sure ok I'll hold a mutant a lot of the
reason why I love this film is because
not only do I think it is it is a great
character origin piece but it is one of
the best done pieces of historical
fiction I've really ever seen in terms
of integrating a completely fictional
character into this alternative history
but beyond that I now believe in the
moral center of the Marvel Universe like
I get why later
Coulson collects his cards to get to a
few of your points just talking about
like some of the other cast members for
penny Carter III got the the connection
between them I I got the the romance and
the attraction between them did I think
she deserved her own series coming out
of that movie no but I also don't hold
that I don't consider about a false of
the movie to your first point about
Hydra I agree with you and that was a
problem I had before the movie came out
when they first said that he's not
fighting the Nazis he's fighting Hydra I
was like why not the Nazis are the
perfect villain
maybe that was their decision because
they wanted to do something with it down
the road but I
don't even know that I don't know why
and I will actually accept that that is
the weakest part of the movie because I
think the Hydra soldiers look stupid and
their weaponry looks stupid if it wasn't
a GI Joe movie I would love it but
within the realism of the universe that
they had created in this Captain America
world even that I agree with you I love
the look of Red Skull I know I was a
little bit let down by his last fight
with Captain America when they're
fighting in the cockpit of that off the
ship I actually don't remember that
fight at all I have distinct memories of
him you're disappearing with the
tesseract right the flash of light but
that actual fight I don't remember a
single thing about it it wasn't a good
it was it was disappointing but the hero
and the spirit more or less of that
movie carried it on its shoulders so
maybe maybe your assessment is right
it was just a fine movie with an
exceptionally great protagonist a great
hero and I think that does elevate it to
make it better than fine I won't
disagree with you I actually thought
hydro is that it's scariest when he
pulled the Hydra agent out of the water
and he's sitting there and he's like you
know cut off one head and seven more up
here or something he bites that poison
time capsule well see that's the version
of Hydra that works and that's the
version of Hydra we got in Winter
Soldier this they they are everywhere
and they are sprouting you won't know
who they are as opposed to these
faceless soldiers with ray guns you know
well all of us are right and all of us
are wrong yeah but I'm the most less
least wrong this is your chance to throw
out your stuff for the people where can
they find you I'll start this time I
have a number of podcasts first the
secret origins podcast which covers the
secret origins comics published by DC in
the 1980s that is available on iTunes
and stitcher
den bathin spies a Star Wars podcast
available on iTunes
you can also occasionally hear me on GI
Joe a real American head cast hosted by
Aaron head Moss Kyle Manning and myself
I'm a leader writer of a comic book from
armor from Rising Sun comics called
armadillo justice the comixology Amazon
go to your
drug store and look for the spinning
rack don't do that and Ryan and I are on
the co-writers of red and green it
already be out and amazing topic you'll
be probably one of the people waiting in
line to get your copy of red and green
and I'm gonna get out of here real quick
because this is getting uncomfortable
until next time this council is
adjourned punchy